GOAL AND AN ASSIST IN THAT ONEZ.
AFTER IT'S PEZZETTA.
ARMIA COMES IN TO HELP OUT. KUL.
RITCHIE HELPS OUT.
WE APPROACH THE 9-MINUTE MARK IN
THE OPENING
BACKLUND BACK
BACKLUND, MANGIAPA
SUZUKI WILL TAKE.
GOES HIGH STICK SIDE.
WORKING IT ACROSS TO KYLINGTON.
KULAK IS OUT OF THE BOX.
TIME TO MAKESTACK.
HAMMOND WORKS THE PUCKREAL HAD
AFTER THAT.
AND THEN THERE'S A TURNOVER IN
THEW DUMPED IN
BY WIDEMAN. MIDDLE GETS
A LITTLE BIT OF HELP HERE.
MANGIAPANE.
WIDEMAN BACKS IN.
TAKE A LOOK SEASON.
NOW MONTREAL ABLE TO SET IT
THIS IS JUST WHAT
BUT A REALLY GOOD RECOVERY SHOT.
MARKSTROM ABLE T THE BENCH.
JOB.
JOHNNY IS THERE.
IT SEEMED AS
THAT'S HOW GALLAGHER HAS TO PLAY
TO
ROLL.
>> Ryan: AND HE'S GONE.TOFFOLI.
WORKS THE PUCK BACK THE OTHER
WAY.
TOFFOLI PUT IT IN FRONT.
NOBODY THEREOUT.
AND AWAY
>> Kelly: WHAT LOOKED TO BE AN
EVEN RUSHBOARDS.
IN FRONT DEFLECTED JUST WIDE.
BETWEEN THE LEGS.
PETRY, HE'S EXHAUSTED.
HE DOESN'T GET ANYTHING O PLAY.
MONTREAL TOOK THE STREAK.
>> Kelly: RIGHT.
>> Rick: LAST TIME CALGARY SAW .
MONTREAL BREAK